welcome to this video bruin player yep
played him once and one so let's see if
I can keep the [ __ ] yeah the good old
Vanko gambit black is really struggling
recently to prove sufficient
compensation in this slide the problem
however said I only know that this with
12 8 a-4 we will probably see that we I
only know that it is probably good for
Wyatt but I don't know I don't know any
any details yeah current theoretical
state of this line is rather rather
bleak for for black but I don't know how
why exactly what the details are do you
go here I don't know mmm I would like to
get in obviously rook b1 b3 night b5
this kind of thing
95 yes rook takes a for those so I
cannot play that so easily if he goes
age 6 what am i doing I don't do a take
or not
I originally wanted to go back to the
two saying that age six could be a
weakness but maybe maybe em this is some
wrong idea psycho Bishop f6 Bishop f6
well that's a bit bit of a problem as
reasoning Bishop c3r okay for
immediately it's not so so easy to to
counter or do I just give away their
porn yeah as mentioned i have to
basically event this over over the board
I rook b8 seems ok for like yeah it's
not helping if you know that it is
probably a good line but you don't know
why exactly that's the case rupee eight
rook FB one who could be three those
kind of things might be happening
I think that b3 is maybe a threat here
so I mean a position of threat b3 droopy
one night b5 would really secure my
extra pawn nicely so he has to do
something against the b3 idea Luke b8
looks very normal I mean I'm not saying
that's the only move but he has to ok so
he didn't didn't do something in that
regard b3 what is he going to play then
see for what ok yeah show me show me
what you got
if he go see form which is sometimes an
idea I have before so okay he's not
reacting to anything here I don't know I
mean probably he didn't have a great
move anyway but ok that's the idea yeah
I am that was the idea preparing
preparing the the e pawn the e pawn push
ok I can take and then he will probably
play ok I can take first and then think
about the details and then you will play
d5 yes ok so probably let's do this okay
one at d5 I'm going to step back with a
king can also take do I want to take not
sure now I'm going to step out of the
long diagonal this is this really
necessary anyway wasn't sure if taking
is helping me in any any regard d 4 i'm
going nite be five this is some yeah
it's a it's a messy position why does a
pawn up and probably it's not not a not
a full compensation but it is some yeah
it is the kind of mess that sometimes
can blow up in your face even if you are
just a pawn up okay so i'm sure we'll
see one not easy to play and light to
see for would be brilliant Knight f3 to
see for 2d three it's not so easy to get
Luke see one was to address see for this
IDM
now do I get things things coordinated
and I don't have three yes really heave
he wants to place you for that much is
clear I can drop back to a three this is
an idea night a three and then to see
for don't know that looks kind of
strange looks lower
hmm
they are my f3 night smut not doing
anything
yeah not very satisfied with the smooth
but I had to head to play something idea
is to go to sea for but yes rook could
be eight you can maybe switch switch
back to join a check to an attack on the
beep porno I have Knight a5 at the
threat don't know if not Queen B seven
or so so great
Andy five is hanging yeah so is giving
giving the material here it's probably
probably not a bad decision it's a much
still fairly fairly Merkley this
position is got c4
hmm can see force is a real problem here
ty morning could have no idea I don't
have 92 year that's a huge problem
we add trying to activate with rook a 6
it's not really what I wanted but that
was a very it was all of a sudden very
difficult yeah the pawns are very quick
I just hope that my activity here can do
something against the King on the
seventh-ranked this kind of things but
the seaport is quick okay here's and
here's a knight c6 trick that sets bad
I seen a movie mmm night-night b8 what
it means yo that we should be five now k
come on white resigns ah what the city
move but ok this is it is very
problematic here here I'm holding again
but it was a bad position hmm so maybe
it wasn't such a great idea here this
I'm sorry night see form my computer
wants to check on e5 with a pretty big
edge now 9 a-5 was my original plan and
I stuck to it but the thing is when you
see them the boot if you see the
position then it is pretty clear that
that this isn't so great I should have
played rooks Luke a 1 here yeah okay it
was just a series of quick moves and
only here I was looking at it again and
this is really not good for yd on those
two pawns they are very strong now
that's just a bad position I didn't find
anything remotely convincing yeah I'm
just in a very very bad shape yeah woo
Kade was much stronger but
so let's let's check i'm really curious
because around here white is just a very
much better rook c8 this is so this is
not how you can play this opening but i
really would like to know how to how to
refute it let's say so look be one yeah
so e six it's the only only counterplay
d5 yeah i don't think that this is bad
after some somewhere around here i need
to need to find improvements yeah it's
all not not completely easy I mean stock
which gives me like plus one almost plus
one but it is still a murky position the
compounds to do this which I didn't
really think of yeah the main idea is to
to limit black's pieces so this pawn is
taking away important squares and the
comp wants to play night a three and be
four next it's not easy at all to play i
mean i agree that probably white should
be better but it's not easy to play and
saw that in the game it wasn't it wasn't
simple to play no no no i went here here
and here this is what the computer wants
to play as an improvement yeah there's
definitely some point to that they are
first covering here and only is then
jumping to see form yeah it is this is a
delicate position the reason why those
banco gambit even if even if the
position is objectively not very good
it is some often quite active so it's
it's it's sometimes easier to play for
black yeah yeah I'm just in in terrible
shape a sort of swindled must have out
of it but the time and so on okay well
thanks for watching